what are we doing I actually don't know
what we're doing today a lot of face
things cutting board no oh I told the
underestimated how disgusting this would
actually be I really do hope this goes
better than this nail we found a
BuzzFeed post that has a list of like
dermatologist fruit DIY facials so we're
gonna try a couple of those out before
we get conventional one
half a teaspoon of lemon juice half a
teaspoon of baking soda and one
tablespoon of honey I don't like deja
with the knife next to me but let's
proceed just stay in your area like that
why don't you all my Saints are going in
here you can see though I want to if it
helps you actually do look totally
stupid right it actually does feel
pretty soft please feel bad
it just feels feels a little clogged up
with honey but honey is just a little
too stinky because it's avocado we got
it took your head back a little
[ __ ] you Jen you look amazing what's
your secret I feel like you're doing a
better job at this than I did maybe not
no come here I'm doing you dope I felt
like it actually really like cleared out
my skin my skin feels really soft right
now it was nice like flapping in your
face though that was fun
your skin won't feel smooth you by the
light and tingly fresh we mix a small
amount of water with this in our palms
and then we apply it to our face see
this one's nice but my face because I'm
not worried it doesn't feel gross and it
smells myself it feels like it's eating
my skin but in a good way oh you all
right don't eat it feels good I just
feel very dry it felt very refreshing to
take it off yeah my god it was very
soothing I would do the seaweed mask
again I would not do the the DIY the to
DIY disasters that preceded it you know
in retrospect we probably shouldn't have
done three masks in a row well you know
we do what we do whatever we want around
here